President Trump is not backing down from
critics who say his Twitter attacks on a
group of progressive Democratic
lawmakers are racist the president
tweeted yesterday they should quote go
back and help fix the totally broken and
crime-infested places from which they
came mr. Trump tweeted again this
morning saying quote when will the
radical left Congress women apologize to
our country he appears to be directing
his attacks at 4:00 at a group of four
freshmen congresswoman all of them
African all of them all of whom are
American citizens Paula Reid is at the
White House Paula the president clearly
wants to be having this conversation
this morning he's continuing the
conversation what do you think his
objective is Tony these tweets come amid
a week of infighting between these more
progressive members of Congress and
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi but if the
president intended to capitalize on
these tensions it backfired as nothing
unites warring factions like a common
enemy he really wants to divide us
against each other
Democrats swiftly denounce the
president's tweet Sunday I believe he's
racist because I hate to means women of
color heeda meets people of color the
president was apparently referencing for
female freshmen House Democrats known as
the squad New York congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes Minnesota's
Elan Omar Rashida to leave of Michigan
and Massachusetts congresswoman Ayanna
Presley all four are American citizens
only one of the lawmakers congresswoman
Omar was born outside the country she
was born in Somalia and became a US
citizen in 2000 all the women responded
on Twitter with omar saying as members
of congress the only country we swear an
oath to is the united states you were
stoking white nationalism president
Trump's tweets came amid a rift in the
Democratic Party that's been brewing
since the passage of the emergency
border aid package the freshman all
voted against the bill and the battle
between them and House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi has escalated in recent days in
his tweet Trump added I'm sure that
Nancy Pelosi would be very happy to
quickly work out free travel
arrangements but Pelosi was quick to
defend the women on Sunday saying the
president's call reaffirms his plan to
make America great again has always been
about making America white
our diversity is our strength and our
unity is our power by the end of the
weekend Republican leadership was silent
and administration officials like the
acting commissioner of US Customs and
Border Protection directed questions to
the president I think that you need to
talk to the president about his specific
tweets well in his tweets last night and
this morning the president doubled down
said he looks forward to challenging
Democrats in 2020 suggesting that at
least he believes this approach will not
hurt him at the ballot box Gail all
right Paula thank you very much